making expensive blockbuster films is an
exercise in high risk versus high reward
though most mega-hit flicks have the
potential to bring in big bucks they
also have the potential to lose a ton of
money so when a low-budget movie becomes
a surprise hit studio execs can rest
easy we're talking about those diamonds
in the rough that were made for less
than ten million dollars but still
managed to gross loads of dough thanks
to positive critical reception awards
season buzz and innovative marketing and
release tactics American Graffiti George
Lucas went on to make big box-office
bucks with the Star Wars franchise but
before he went to a galaxy far far away
he went to Modesto California for his
coming-of-age drama American Graffiti at
the time Lucas was a fairly unknown
director so he had a hard time getting
financial support for his project
Universal eventually agreed to make the
movie with just a $750,000 budget
however they still questioned Lucas's
vision asking him to hire a new editor
and recut the film after he turned in
the finished product the studio was
worried about releasing the film in
theaters but employees who had seen and
loved the film eventually convinced them
despite the movie's troubles making it
to the big screen it wound up being
remarkably well-received earning 5 Oscar
nominations including Best Picture and
Best Director for Lucas the film was
immensely popular at the box office as
well pulling in 115 million dollars
making it the 15th highest-grossing
pg-rated film of all time when adjusted
for inflation lost in translation
the definitive fish-out-of-water drama d
lost in translation one writer director
Sofia Coppola and Oscar for Best
Original Screenplay and earned three
other nominations including Best Picture
but the Bill Murray LED movie which
explored alienation and existential
dread against a bustling Tokyo backdrop
wasn't just an award season favorite the
four million dollar flick earned 119
point seven million dollars at the
worldwide box office
I'm trying to organize a prison-break
I'm looking for like an accomplice lost
in translation which followed the
complicated relationship between
Scarlett Johansson's aimlessly Yale
graduates Charlotte and Marie's aging
movie star Bob Harris first opened on
just 23 screens earning a total of nine
hundred twenty-five thousand
eighty-seven dollars to put that into
perspective that's an average of forty
thousand two hundred twenty one dollars
per theater the highest per theater
average for a limited release in 2003
Annabel Annabel didn't buck the negative
reviews many horror movies face but the
6.5 million dollar creepy doll film made
a killing at the box office the movie
very very narrowly lost the David
Fincher's gone girl in its opening
weekend but still managed to pull in an
impressive 37 point 1 million dollars
Annabel strong opening exceeded the
initial 20 million dollar expectations
at least in part thanks to the movie's
popularity on social media the movie
also had the benefit of being spawned
from another popular low-budget horror
series the conjuring franchise which
came from horror maven James Wan the
movie went on to make an impressive 257
million dollars worldwide The Blair
Witch Project
the found-footage horror film The Blair
Witch Project wasn't just a cultural
phenomenon it was also a box-office hit
the 1999 film about a group of student
filmmakers who hunt down a local urban
legend was made for just $60,000 but
went on to make two hundred forty six
point eight million dollars at the
worldwide box office including 140 point
five million dollars domestic this is
even more impressive when considering
that the film was shot in just eight
days with a partially improvised script
like many of the movies on this list the
Blair Witch Project benefited from an
innovative release schedule rolling out
slowly to spark interest the movie was
screened at the Sundance Film Festival
without much fanfare and audiences were
left wondering if they'd just seen a
horror movie or the scariest documentary
ever building on this excitement
filmmakers used a viral marketing
campaign one of the first to rely on the
Internet to hook viewers while still
maintaining the film's mysterious air
get out Jordan Peele was already an
established comedy actor when he made
his feature film directorial debut with
get out a horror film which he made for
just 4.5 million dollars the movie wound
up being a massive success earning 225
million dollars worldwide it was buoyed
by near-perfect critical reviews
not to mention viewers conversations
surrounding the movie which pushed
people to hit up their local theaters to
see what all the fuss was about
thanks to its innovative premise and
some smart marketing techniques get out
blew audiences away and earned thirty
three point three million dollars on its
opening weekend alone buzz forget out
was so strong that the movie managed to
earn four Oscar nominations despite the
fact that it was released almost a full
year before nominations were announced
and the fact that the Academy has
traditionally overlooked horror movies
peels debut wound up being the most
profitable film of 2017
earning a 630 percent return on
investment for production company bloom
house Juno penned by author screenwriter
Diablo Cody Juno earned four Oscar
nominations including Best Picture Best
Director for Jason Reitman and Best
Actress in a leading role for its star
Ellen Page and a win for Best Original
Screenplay after it hit theaters in 2007
the film featured page as juno macguff a
high schooler who debates her options
during a surprise pregnancy
the charming indie comedy was made on
just a 7.5 million dollar budget with
star Jennifer Garner even taking a pay
cut to help the movie keep costs down
but thanks to its witty pitch-perfect
writing and strong appeal to teens and
young women it ended up being a surprise
box-office success bringing in 231
million dollars worldwide little miss
sunshine back up a minute you know what
a loser is a real loser is somebody
that's so afraid of not winning they
don't even try
the tragic comic 2006 indie flick Little
Miss Sunshine which earned the love of
critics and fans alike chronicled the
trials and tribulations of young olive
Hoover played by Abigail Breslin who
ropes her family into a cross-country
road trip so she can compete in the
Little Miss Sunshine beauty pageant
it also earned four Oscar nominations
including Best Picture which translated
to two well-deserved wins not too shabby
for a movie that was made for just eight
million dollars it ended up becoming a
box-office behemoth earning one hundred
point five million dollars worldwide
you're not nearly as stupid as you look
Fox Searchlight the studio that
distributed the film clearly saw the
box-office potential in Little Miss
Sunshine right off the bat buying the
film for 10.5 million dollars after a
standing ovation at the first screening
caused a bidding war having that much
buzz around the film right out of the
gate got film enthusiasts excited while
the quality of the movie led to a long
and successful box-office run My Big Fat
Greek Wedding My Big Fat Greek Wedding
was just a few days shy of spending a
whole year in theaters and during that
time the five million dollar romantic
comedy went from a low-budget film with
a few big names to a massive money maker
bringing in three hundred sixty eight
point seven million dollars worldwide
that box-office success was very unique
the movie opened to just five hundred
ninety seven thousand three hundred
sixty-two dollars from 108 theaters but
it continued to build up impressive
box-office totals throughout its run
eventually hitting the number two spot
after 20 weeks the movie spent 17
consecutive weeks in the top 10 the
movie success was truly unprecedented as
most movies usually see a downward trend
after their opening weekend's rocky
[Music]
jewel rocky rocky may not be the top
grossing film and the long-running
franchise at the box office but it's 117
point 2 million dollar worldwide was
especially impressive when you consider
that the film starring a then-unknown
Sylvester Stallone had a measly 1
million dollar budget in addition to its
impressive box office haul the film won
three Oscars including Best Picture
Stallone also earned an Oscar nomination
for writing the script for the movie but
despite its astronomical success he
actually had a hard time getting it made
Stallone said he went through about 20
different incarnations of the film
before he landed on the
project but even then it wasn't easy
producers Erlin Winkler and Bob chartoff
had to mortgage their homes and use
their personal savings to finance the
film all that effort clearly paid off
the rocky franchise holds the top four
spots for highest-grossing boxing films
most recently taking over the box office
with 2015's Creed which also was an
award season favorite snagging Stallone
and Oscar nomination for Best Supporting
Actor saw 2004's torture flick saw
didn't just make 100 3.9 million dollars
against a minuscule 1.2 million dollar
budget the movie also managed to launch
a lucrative horror franchise but the
original saw was able to achieve its
initial box-office Heights by using
strong word-of-mouth to hold onto
viewers throughout its october and
november box office run saw proof
popular with young viewers with 60% of
the opening weekend audience under 25
years old that's likely thanks to the
flicks young director then newcomer
James Wan who managed to make the movie
in just 18 days while keeping the budget
low the franchise has continued to build
on its strong start and although it is
stumbled at points the eight films
together still have brought in a total
of nine hundred seventy six point three
million dollars worldwide the most
recent release 2017 s jigsaw pulled in
100 2.9 million dollars worldwide
against a 10 million dollar budget
proving just how impressive saws initial
feat was split em night Shyamalan went
low-budget for his 2017 horror flick
split making the James McAvoy starring
thriller for only nine million dollars
this decision wound up working well for
the twisty director with the film
pulling in two hundred seventy eight
point five million dollars worldwide and
holding on to the number one spot for
its first three weekends at the domestic
box office split an indirect sequel to
Siobhan's mm film unbreakable featured
McAvoy as a man with what appears to be
the associative identity disorder who
kidnaps three teenage girls the movie
received positive reviews from critics
earning a 76% on Rotten Tomatoes and was
nominated for best thriller film at the
Saturn Awards split became Shyamalan s
fifth film to pass 100 million dollars
at the box office
proving that the director still
has the power to bring in large
audiences however splits low budget made
that figure even more impressive
Paranormal Activity go ahead roll your
eyes you were expecting this one but
whether you're tired of hearing about it
or not paranormal activities success
story is one for the ages it's not often
a movie with a budget of $15,000 grosses
193 point 5 million bucks worldwide the
micro budget horror flick was shot in
just seven days on a handheld video
camera by Israeli director Oren Peli a
video game designer with no past film
experience after the movie terrified
legendary director Steven Spielberg
studio execs began to take notice
paramount ultimately bought the film
with the intention to reshoot it with a
higher budget however when a test
screening blew audiences away they
decided to release belly's version of
the film after drafting an alternate
ending paranormal activities success was
partly due to positive reviews sitting
at 83 percent on Rotten Tomatoes
paramount also implemented an innovative
marketing strategy for the movie putting
it in limited release and letting it
build buzz before setting it into wide
release the weekend before Halloween in
its first weekend and wide release the
little ghost flick that could earn the
number one spot with 21 point 1 million
dollars
[Music]